five months ago a movie came out in the
movie theaters call and I just listened
and I was looking forward to seeing it
it's called the witch right yes like the
goat one and that yeah and I go to
aircar if and I go any wonder watch the
which I thought the worst movie I've
ever seen just don't bother don't bother
I go why because it's just not scary
it's artsy fartsy it's not good it sucks
you're gonna hate it
right we just saw it [ __ ] loved it
damn and then you know what I remember
he liked the equalizer
what Denzel but he didn't like Mad Max
and he didn't like madmen that's a weird
one too not like Mad Max so if you ever
Eric if you're listening you [ __ ] okay
I'm never gonna ask you for your advice
because you're you don't know what
you're talking about
I like the witch which was great where
does that rank for you guys in horror
films like out of ten you know what it
on its own as a horde phone necessarily
I would view it more of a psychological
yummy drama like you know we remind me
of the feeling Jacob's Ladder you ever
see that yeah so it's not a full let me
ask you do you see it Jacob / yeah I
know what it is I've seen it
then have you why did you go you said
Jacob slider I was it oh I know that
movie it's Jacob's Ladder is Tim Robbins
when he was young and it's a it's a mind
[ __ ] it's such a good movie and it's
scary in that way where just the whole
thing the the ambiance of the movie has
just that this weird
you mean tone there's uncomfortable like
creepy vibe to it and it's in the world
you know it's so well defined that it
just affects you psychologically even
the witch like the language the
everything about it was just unique to
me or unique to my brain to where it
kept me interested even though we
started the movie at 3 in the morning
and usually I'll doze off if we start a
movie that later yeah but it kept me
interested I wanted to know what was
around the corner each time each time
and it's just like whenever you mix
religion yeah with white people I'm
sorry I'm just being real it's like most
girls in isolation I
halation those three religion isolation
and white people are the scariest
because there were so many like
underlying themes to it it wasn't just
you know religion or like possible
you know witches or whatever it was
there was so much of like a theme about
family and being in isolation and having
to rely on your family and just you know
whatever form that they had yeah and
they were in the middle of nowhere
yeah and there's a scene I don't care
because you haven't seen it I'm just
saying right there's a scene it you
always think when you see white people
film like this you go only white people
could do this because there's why I'll
tell you why because there's a scene in
it where the daughter loses the baby
right if an Asian family if you lost if
I lost my brother Steve yeah and we were
in the woods yeah my dad would lose me
too yeah it would you would like it
would be I would even met I'd be dead
yeah he'd kill me yeah or we would make
me go out in the forest and to find the
[ __ ] thing no you don't come home
into it you get Steve yeah yeah I mean
and I just be in the woods just like
Steve you know he they forgave her
pretty right they were kind of like oh
the baby's gone George George what's
wrong with you people have responsible
[Music]